hello everyone it was a pretty wild day
yesterday at the world rapper
championship and the results after five
rounds are extremely interesting I will
get back to that after I showed you this
game this is a game from round five
you've seen that Magnus Carlsen started
the tournament with a loss against the
Bou his old nemesis but here he faces a
roost on cousin John of Grandmaster from
use beckysan he was world a feeder world
champion from 2004 to 2005 after Ruslan
ponomaryov
he was a longtime second to Vishwanath
on and he also trained Sergey kurakin
and Fabiano Caruana so a great player
himself and he helped create a lot of
great players here he faces Magnus
Carlsen and Carson has the white pieces
and this is one of the good things with
lower tank controls rapid and Blitzer
you will often see an e4 game followed
by some interesting variations so Carson
place efore custom channel goes c5 to
Sicilian defence Knight to f3 we have e
6 d 4 ck occurs Knight captures and
Knight to c6 the diamond of variation
Knight to c3 and Queen to c7 the
bhastrika variation of the time on of in
the g4 immediately Carlsen lashes out
with the pawns we have a 6 preparing b5
also preventing any of the Knights to
jumping to be 5 and h4 by Carlsen b5 we
have Knight to c6 capturing D captures
on c6 and Queen to f3 and here a5 is
played which is a good move
maybe maybe another option since Carson
started a very aggressive in in the
opening maybe a move like b4 for example
after night b1 c5 may be prepared Bishop
to b7 and go after the e4 pawn but
custom jonno goes for a different idea
he plays d5 and Carson continues to push
the pawns g5 and of course custom jonov
will not Castle kingside Bishop to e6
we have Bishop to h3 our custom John of
exchanges Bishop submission captures
rook captures and Bishop to c5 now
Bishop to d2 Carlsen prepares the
queenside castle
we have queenside castle by both players
and f6 now we have h 5 and f captures on
g5 and Bishop captures on g5 now there's
a double attack on the Rotunda eight
Rock characters on d1 Knight captures on
d1 and Queen to d7 pressuring the rook
on h3 also placing the Queen on a nice
opened e-file Queen to b3 and this was a
this was already an interesting move but
it's the wrap you don't really have time
I have to find a move like Queen to c3
Queen the c3 attacks the dark square
bishop and the e5 pawn and after you
prevent this then comes Queen to a3
threatening the a6 pawn to capture it
with check and Queen to f8 check so this
would already be quite the advantage for
Carlsen but okay after Queen to d7
Carlsen goes for Queen to b3 we had
Knight to f6 and rook to d3 would
attempt on the Queen and Queen to g4
Bishop to e3 and this was definitely the
critical moment in the game here
actually the best idea for black is the
block this would Bishop to d4 and after
a move like f3 attacking the Queen the
Queen can't capture because simply
Bishop captures there was an attack on
the Queen you just lost the piece so
after f3 Queen to d7 actually and after
h6g captures on h6 and King to be won
white would definitely have the
advantage here but like black could
maybe hold on for example Queen to e7
you do have to get the Queen out of the
way
since c3 is a big threat and after
Bishop captures pawn caspere's and rook
captures you would be up against to
passed pawns but but you know maybe
maybe black could hold this but after
Bishop to e3 a custom journal didn't go
for Bishop before he played Bishop
captures on e3 Carlsen play Knight
captures on e3 this comes with a temple
on the Queen and the Queen captures on
e4 and this Queen captures on e4 was
actually a pretty big blunder but it's
it's very hard to find a move for black
in this position here Collison played
clean to e6 this comes with the check
King the b8 was played and now h6 you
can't capture you lose the knight on f6
so custom jonno tried Queen to h1 would
check another idea was maybe rook to e8
but this doesn't help you okay this does
come with a temp on the Queen but simply
Queen to b6 this is with check King
moves and now simply H captures on g7
and now you're threatening to capture
the night if he moved the knight to any
square then if Queen to d7 will pick up
the rock on e8 the it's a winning
position for white spectra h6 custom
John of tried Queen to h1 would check
rook to d1 blocking again will attempt
on the Queen and now Queen captures on
h6
but this doesn't help cousin simply
played Queen captures on c6 and in this
position and this is move 25 so
definitely a miniature roast on custom
jonov resigned to the game what would
follow I as you can see there's a really
no move for black this the Queen is
really controlling the night here
the knight can't really jump too many
squares if you try it and develop with
something like rook to see it as simply
Queen b6 check the King gay now Queen
captures King bhp after some b5 and
after something like King to a seven
then rook comes to d6 again blocking the
night
the threat is rook to a6 checkmate
there's really only one way to stop this
for example Queen h1 check Knight blocks
and now Queen to b7 this does a stop
checkmate but simply Queen check in gate
and rook to be six wins the Queen and
the game and this is just one variation
but this is the best defense for black
any other defense loses a lot quicker
than this so this was a well-played game
by Magnus Carlsen and he after that loss
in round 1 he gets the three and a half
points and after five rounds he is
currently in 22nd place first and second
place is shared between Joao Paulo
beador with four and a half points and
Vladimir the federal save followed by I
think 10 or 11 players with with 4
points so it's a definitely gonna be an
interesting day too and especially day 3
since and anything can happen this
doesn't really mean anything
any player can win this event and it's a
a lot of you have requested the game
which Anand versus Peter like oh so I
will definitely show that game next but
everyone feel free to suggest any game
you enjoyed from the world rapid
championship just use use a hashtag
suggestion and I will show it and I
would like to thank everyone for sending
me your photos and videos of you
teaching someone else chest there's
still time until New Year's so there
will be the email in the description
below so any of you that still decide to
do it are welcome to send me or photos
and videos for me to mix together in one
big New Year's video so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank other than us or our fire
and the Luigi colony for a contribution
to my channel thanks a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here both of them
will be from the world rapid
championship thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon